hey Rob do you float oh hey they all
float so we're uh doing a commentary on
the friending story right oh yes and if
neverending story floats
um neverending story and I can you do
you better let it out ha ha ha ok ok we
better actually talking about this ah
wants to talk about Michael ears you
know what I might do that because that
because that one is so awful I don't
think even Stephen King fans can defend
yes my movie is just all sorts of bad
for as much as we make fun of this movie
yeah we really don't like it yeah no
it's and I will say this is one of the
better ones but that's not saying much
because Stephen King films there yeah
well you know what it is the stuff with
the kids the kid actors are actually
pretty good
yeah the the flashbacks were pretty good
the adult actors are actually pretty bad
how is the shocking far you think it'd
be the other way around with the kid
actors entry they actually managed to
find a whole bunch of convincing child
actors and I kind of wish they'd just
ditched the whole like Stephen King
story and just rewrote it from scratch
like you see these Chavez like you know
what screw it we're just gonna write a
different story because we've got great
talent and the fine thing is that that
whiskey that's actually um Jim that the
friend of ours he has that whiskey and
yeah dear yeah and I replaced it with
apple juice it's not real but he just
saw that a video I did tell he just saw
they what uh I think he I think he cried
a little cuz that's a cheap whiskey no
that's that answer I good whiskey too um
so yeah should we do the drinking game
along with you is we're already in Maine
no no we won't survive we slowed circuit
these wee little flashback in point the
movies shot like kind of like a bad soap
opera no it is a bad soap yeah the adult
scenes just play like you're watching
the soap opera and jump yeah well
back this the second film we've done
with him right third I think yeah you
know it is a shame
yeah sidekicks neverending story too in
this one all the controversial ones keep
popping up in my videos I'm not doing it
on purpose
hello how are you all right down here
I'm British
red balloons now the one thing I have to
say oh yeah these Ivy walk the organs
where's lip why once I have his lips are
working I just don't get how we're
supposed to take it seriously and so
many people were terrified and I
understand if you have a fear of clowns
that's totally good we got that but like
but like I never had a fear of clowns
except for killer clowns from outer
space which is the most terrifying
horror movie but obviously I mean none
of us can sleep because of that movie
yeah so I didn't I just I can get it I'm
like he's really funny like I love Tim
Curry that's going that's the one scary
scene I think I'd say that is the one
scary scene and that really got me it
got me as an adult - I just like G so
that was good oh but something I do have
to bring up that I feel was in this day
actually everything I say about Stephen
King in here I still sort of hold up -
just buy what you know Stephen King fans
you don't want to kill us and stuff but
I mean the one thing where I think I did
screw up is that I say it's a
supernatural element that will not be
explained actually if anything Stephen
King / explains the supernatural element
as it are right you could argue the
movie the movies do it work no but the
books I mean the books actually going to
way too much detail was the first two
different yaaaay Stephen King's the
first to admit phase like I wrote myself
into a corner it's like what do I do
giant spider and it's like tied it's
basically tied to the rest of his mythos
which is basically like sort of a quasi
Cthulhu thing it's it just gets nutty
like I was kind of like you know what
you were probably just okay with the
killer clown yeah no actually I heard a
story like this I don't think it needs
to be fully explained just maybe a hint
and start it's it in the movie anyway
very unsatisfactory I did read the book
when I was younger up I don't have the
best knowledge of it I do remember yeah
like the girl was pretty much a whore no
like she had to sleep with everybody to
get rid of memories
I don't know I care about how work but
she's like really ridiculous I'm sorry
so don't sleep around it's like if you
like the book fine but it's if you read
it it's kind of kind of goofy
you know and people like to tell us like
oh oh you have to read the book oh the
book waits that I did that didn't make
the book any good it's like yeah the
book is better than the movie but the
book was really goofy to people like
well they left this out they left out
the reason why she has to have sex with
everybody and I'm like yeah you ain't
never get yeah say that again with a
straight face they had to leave out the
reason why she's sleeping with all the
other boys and like yeah okay what what
I always know what I usually find about
Stephen King books is that I enjoy them
while I'm reading them and then after
I'm done I go Wow
wait a minute and I start start adding
things up I'm like that that was a we're
friggin story hey wait a minute I didn't
like this and so I think the pros are
very good that they're written well and
that you know you have a story and it's
told well but the story itself is not
that good usually with the exceptions I
think my problem with Stephen King is I
don't find a supernatural story scary if
you do that's cool I'm not you know
that's fine but you know it's different
strokes for different folks and none of
his supernatural stories scare me that
much The Shining the book sorry I like
the Kubrick film a lot better like the
book really didn't scare me at all and a
lot of his best books that I like have
little supernatural elements in it you
know you go a lot of the short stories
as if you lose Shawshank Redemption
Green Mile Dolores Claiborne a lot of
the ones I like really are not like
about yeah you know we should live like
Goblin we should list the ones we
actually do like or else people are
gonna kill us again well we say yeah I'd
never agree mile but you say it's good
Gerald's game was very good Dolores
Claiborne misery is unbelievably good um
misery is great well that that one
that's like our worst nightmare
we're gonna run into a crazy family what
did you say about stiva actually we
lived bad that was the Stephen King
review like all of us in the Kathy Bates
people came by you didn't like Stephen
King oh you need that Jay okay yes I was
one of mine
but um it I know I've always said that
Stephen King doesn't scare me but his
fans on the other hand his fans can be
very scary they're very very very
defensive that's all I can say and and I
get it cuz even King gets picked on a
lot but you know you gotta have a sense
of humor about it Stephen King is the
first to admit that like yeah he's not
Shakespeare Stephen came by the way if
you ever hear on my interviews and so
he's an awesome guy yeah
that's what kills me it's just like all
of his fans get so uptight but like
he'll be the first say yeah I don't know
what he was doing I was on crack when I
wrote this book I India this man's like
oh you can't see that it's so awesome
masterpiece that was like he's a sense
of humor about his work come on
and I like the idea of this drinking
game - I thought this well you know I
could do something a little different
cuz there's only you always had to find
ways this'll Bionic Woman sound effect I
don't know people got that but um
there's only so many ways you can react
to something and getting drunk I'm like
I haven't gotten drunk yet
that'd be fun is uh I don't even
remember I was gonna say that's cuz
you're drinking right now that's right
they're like this guy that's cuz Oh
Randa Cal coholic and a Stephen King
we'll talk about a drinking game um yeah
like some people tried to catch us on
like little things like oh well in in
this story he his Christian allegories
were we're so huge and we're so pro
Christian that that doesn't kind of was
like yeah that doesn't take away the
obvious anti Christian allegories in
other things he's written just because
he's got a positive side on one hand
that doesn't mean that he didn't have a
negative side on the other so it still
counts you know one way or another it's
still kind of sloppy and I I had to me
if that was where alcohol you would not
see its billing as much I'd be much more
cautious about it cuz that's my baby you
know and I said allegories I meant
stereotypes
somebody will know there's a Stephen
King I'm fan out there it's like
literary term fry it looks like South
Green there yeah does that keep being a
Boy Scout ever come back in the movie I
just realized it's never really
referenced after that it's just he's a
boy scout if it is a boy scout let's go
find a dead body and they build it I
think I said that like what the hell I
like are they building a dam why you're
right cuz it's fucking big like that
what else you gonna do fucking baby used
to live in New England and Maine has
this bit of a reputation much like I
wanna a thinks of Wisconsin and yeah
that's kind of sometimes like why are
they building names cuz its main I think
I I have nothing personally against
Maine so just just letting you know yeah
I I don't play that many drinking games
I never have I think I play one drinking
game it was the Red Dwarf drinking game
that we made up and was whenever
Crichton explains something scientific
area 10 yeah I don't think we got
through one episode yet I feel like I
just I throw it all up man I was nasty
he passed out and I was like well this
is great cuz I was the only one stole
away I think yeah it was like one
episode I'm like oh my god you don't
realize how much Crichton explained
sciency stuff like all the time I love
playing like Sim Sim City like mm and
minesweeper like on like your
girlfriend's computer is something the
overbearing parent of Gavin yeah the
overbearing mother if she were a crazy
Christian she would have been straight
out of Carrie but you know we've
switched it up a little at least hooray
and it's one of those this review
actually was a little longer there's
about three or four jokes I told it's a
Stephen magnet mark it's longer than the
Bible to begin with it's already so I
think this is the longest review and I
just couldn't believe how long it was
when I looked it over at the same time
it goes really fast and some about the
drinking game and the jokes and the fast
pace of it it seems to fly by pretty
quick though people were torn about some
like the drinking game some thought it
was just you doing hammy acting and I'm
like well what else is yeah what else
five do you watch the site yeah I does
ask it just leave yeah if that happened
to me this is like I know do pull it
Dana Barrett you see the dog in the
fridge and it says yeah you scream and
you run and you call ghostbusters I
think there's look at this even when I
was a kid I was like really did they
really just do that stop-motion that's
fear I can do day yeah that's like
frickin Large Marge going on there when
I um you know when I was watching
there's once you were like he tries to
leave and I think they try to make it
look like the whatever the poles are the
showers are blocky and but they're so
obviously this huge space where you can
walk out it's all I have to do is climb
under it really I I think the only two
scenes that I thought he was scared I
thought the intro was well done he's
kind of in the sewer you can't see much
of him you know and then I think there
was some scene where he's digging
digging everybody's graves it was sort
of a creepy image but yeah there's very
little that very well yeah I just like
to wake up to that in the morning
alright how's it goin I don't know we're
watches on the AVI I don't know the FLV
on the site maybe there's a low is like
one frame in there you see if the clown
in the middle it's like damnit I hate it
when those get in but oh I don't think I
ever made a nightcore joke you didn't
know I had one knife core joke at neck
core joke gum at the end there was we
did the the lines rice that I've got the
the script ready for you when I knock on
the door that's right the alternate take
was it was like hey Doug do you think I
look like that asshole from it you know
the one who also played the judge in
Night Court
no as I had like the fedora died I was
like I kind of look like him with the
vest in the fedora at you I want to use
that I think the sound or something got
cut up part of the line or something
like that so yeah a lot of it was
language like what no Night Court jokes
is like well we did have that one line
when it got cut I love Tim Curry and
those I really do you know is he's like
mr. freeze and Batman and Robin it's
just like he's the heart
he's the ATP's the 80-ton gorilla in the
room is like you have no clue what he's
gonna do you just know it's gonna be
goofy and entertaining like that's the
thing I found him immensely entertaining
people just like how could you know like
he was like no I loved him but he wasn't
scary he was
larious you know I just I have made like
a bajillion fresh prints jokes like in
terms of the salt a discussion is one of
the greatest shows ever made well you
know what the show is awesome the song
is like a bajillion levels of us and I
just love using I think people always
like people never get tired of it Doug
they were making trouble in the
neighborhood you know she got one little
fight his mom got scary Mary she's like
oh you know God just remind me of the
commercial the commercial episode came a
few episodes after this just like you
know what what if this was the summer of
Apple Jacks not oh my god a clown a
fucking clockwork I'll never watch an
Apple Jacks commercial the same way
again oh my god a clown a fucking clown
dear God
don't forget the fucking clown he's just
having so much fun later he's adorable
how can you be scared by that you know
what I would invite him to my nephew's
birthday party I was probably gonna hear
this and I'll never be invited ever over
again he's coming to your bachelor party
I want you to know it's like a kid
Schmidt's you should be an adult partner
he's that be a ton of fun biz
this is fun yeah this really worked out
surprisingly this made me realize I
think Stephen King's it would have been
a much better comedy we're working as
many jokes as you can just with movies
these people about it
yeah I really what killed me is I felt
such camaraderie amongst the kids in
this movie I never got that really out
of the adults and it's maybe it's cuz
kids get along better they're all kids
are having fun they're on a movie set I
don't know but even they I mean the
adults they read their lines zero notice
I do know I just realized what it is
when they're kids they have to be here
cuz they're they're the losers they're
the outcasts and they're constantly
being picked on when they're adults
they're like their lives are normal now
everything is happy and they are a lot
of the time they're supposed to be
portrayed that way lie
they're great of course except for the
fact you know the clown the fucking
clown the motherfucking clone oh yeah
the cloud comes back but how do you
always see them you see them for two
seconds everything's great and then we
say something's wrong you go to
flashback it's like and what they're
happy they're just they're not very good
when doing happy like when that one
guy's doing is stand-up routine like you
know before they find out that the best
friend is dead
I mean it's terrible it's sad it was I
look to get that audience look at me not
make happy days joke I can't remember I
don't think I do
and like I talked about this before I
hate hate hate cardboard cut-out bullies
in movies oh and this one they're just
shocked so boring and it's such a pain
way into why could you know they're
gonna get there come on then there's
bullies and then there's like Stephen
King's but I don't know who terrorized
King as a kid but man does he take it
out like I mean these are this like
beyond boys this is just a psychotic
killer like and he's like that in the
book it's like that I'm just like wow
you really man I'm so sorry I don't know
what happened to you but thank God he
writes because we don't want to know
what else he'd be doing if he wasn't
how many people get the Lucie right they
they have to get the loot Lucie
reference the even like two-year-olds
get the Lucy reference I think yeah
here's where it gets like really slurry
and I was concerned because we're not
even halfway through the actual movie
yet I realize I'm doing that
oh Claire I love lava blast Jarell this
movie will explode in five days
contained within is all my knowledge of
the universe now here's something a lot
gets up kids some a lot of fans tell me
they say that well the reason you wanted
to scare the kids is cuz they taste so
much better I was like yeah well well
first of all he didn't we know with a
brother he a temporary fasten plus your
fucking killer Klown you go boo ah
munch boom there you go no I mean you
know and that was always my problem that
in the book to us is like you know what
food is food if these guys really are
getting so smart that they may be a
threat to you just eat them who cares if
you add salt to it
it's still food now the thing that sucks
is on the DVD uh you know she does her
little bit oh no she doesn't a little
yell but then originally it cuts back to
the it sign and it says a little to be
continued at the Bobby here Tim Curry go
wow and it was great but it's not on the
DVD and I miss it I misses a little
laughing this is late
oh she deserves an award for that yeah
he really took the time like it you know
what she's gotta be said this will
calming down yeah this will explain
everything it's gonna write it I forget
and there's a whole there's a whole
scene where like they reminisce but I
mean it's like they go riding on a bike
and play catch together instead it's
really silly I love always like so
you're a bachelor i it's yeah apparently
running around talking about killer
clowns and serial killers in this city
doesn't get you laid a Seth Green
doesn't look like that I love it a lot
of these kids really a lot of these
dolts don't look like how the kids look
like at all you really can't see them
growing up yeah you know I look like
these people and so much of it was based
on balloons which not not scary that's
good I'm sorry hey balloon takes my life
at the other step
people love that move and I just get
playing it over and over and over I mean
like I said obviously this is stretched
out but we this is fresh just like he's
doing this guy's trying to talk he just
keeps twirling that thing around look at
that he just bestows our joke it's like
he just kept doing this snickering well
keep rolling to work today I can do
whatever the hell I want cuz I'm Tim
Curry Bessel's people love wah ha all
right why was he even doing really like
he's more of just a nuisance than a
threat I just be annoyed and then I
probably really start laughs he's a good
clown I just like walk up to him and
slap him in the face but you know what
just go the fuck away will you please
you know I take it back there was once
he was a little creepy
I didn't quit just for time but she goes
in
and like I think she's talking this old
woman or something she starts to like
melt and peels like their eyes are
disappear yeah that's real baby I saw
poltergeist and they edit their only
years before so man there's like a solid
five minutes of just the camera spinning
around this fucking table Oh God
oh this is when he appears in the moon I
literally am like positon cuz I just
burst out laughing I'm like this is just
so goofy people people look you're
afraid of that look at that you know it
face your fears people who were scared
by this movie it's Tim Curry and white
makeup in the moon this is freaking
Nightmare Before Christmas
oh hell that was so hard to do because
the camera moves on that shot he had to
sort keep it steady this is like the
Evil Dead this is like Evil Dead 2 here
I mean this is just silly just so much
stuff happens in this fucking movie
that's so long did we do the Jeffrey
Dahmer wine oh yeah now I said that guy
out loud and Doug started writing it
down I'm like no no we can't are you
serious he's like nah I'm doing it I
forget I forget I say stand-up or dinner
theater I said I said it was like bad
dinner theater at Jeffrey Dahmer's house
now you know it's why held my fingers up
with holding up three fingers I do it
was at the German way or whatever words
the thumb and the two finger so a lot of
times when I do it my thumb is covered
and people are like oh you know the two
fingers is like no it was three it's
just the German way what is it a
inglorious basterds referencing yeah
that's at you how I found out about
Germans do it that way I'm like oh I
would have gotten shot by the Nazis I
love that that's a great and I actually
if you notice the to care just in the
back or you have it and you have the
Wolfman and the mummy who appear in the
movie as as a story it's a series of a
lot of times interesting ideas that just
don't gel together ya know if there's a
great ideas in here like and then it
just but it never quite gel together
like killer clown interesting using fear
interest it's like forbidden plan it's
like okay that's interesting this is
like but it never quite meshes
together it's like Stephen King was kind
of like one person getting into a one
book item I like Stephen King the most
when there's at least going out when
there's simpler stories and there is a
thing I can remember I've referenced it
but there's the thing where they lose
their memory as they leave the town
because again there's this weird thing
with the town the talent is just bad I
guess I mean I'm sure it'll explain it
in them you know what they go back to
the Middle Earth or whatever it is it's
cry you know is mythology you know but
had in the book you have to read other
Stephen King books to get the full story
behind what Pennywise is and I'm just
like you know how do you fit all that in
one movie like especially it's like yeah
you look in it's like it's about a
killer clown that terrorizes children
okay the killer class supernatural I
okay well lucky one kind of change into
the other things all right the killer
clown is this agent spider from years
ago it says Lanka it's like okay okay
just keep it simple
came to this planet on an asteroid and
it's like no critic you have to read
this book and then five other books to
get the whole and each one is 18 hundred
pages long and no we have lives yes I
don't want he has the dark tower for
that add to it as it goes with those
balloons um I tried one with just a
balloon and then one with the eyes and
by far the eyes were creepier but but
just having the balloon itself was
surprisingly kind of scary it's like huh
you actually can make up a little scary
these two mr flibble shot from Red Dwarf
yeah never thought of that you're right
that's exactly where it came from
I don't get what the upset ever
everybody's like what oh it's that
bodies float well yeah I get that but
why mention it over and over why is that
scary you know what everybody needs a
tagline it's as mo is signature yeah and
look at really like come on I understand
if you're you know seven years old and
you watch this moment it's terrifying
like believe me I get that but
as an adult and people like freak goes
like no we scary I was like watch it
again as an adult it does not really
hold up as well you you just stand it
unless you're afraid of clowns that's
the only thing I'll buy that sure but if
you're not afraid of clowns I mean you
just had a dog in a clown suit attacking
an orderly man what like what look at
sly yeah never mind you the shot for
more comment to you where the guy
changes into a wolf and they can't show
the wolf so they just show the effect
they probably got it from this movie
they probably got that shot from here oh
yeah and this is this is how she knows
it and again at you I bet you anything
in the book this is probably better
doing it in the book it does make more
sense but they did not translate any of
this Janee but in the book it makes
sense in that he explains it but I don't
think it was really all that like you
know it's interesting you know it's like
like just talking just about that just
about the town and how bad is is you
know then tell story about a killer
clown then tell story about this agent
giant killer spider you know then it's
like just split it up you don't that
they're all mauling it's almost like a
it's almost like a Mad Libs is like
there's a killer clown and six kids and
I think that's rock-a-doodle actually
yeah or is that so mean like I find
myself using well but no it's a very
good point because that's a problem that
a lot of the bad films we review have
which is they just it feels like a man
lives is like too much stuff going on
like the screenwriters just could not or
the original writer could not figure out
and we're gonna get it for that but
could not figure out how to just put all
of these disparate elements together or
maybe they should have been put together
maybe you just could have simplified the
story was the one this I actually I
didn't but some people like killer
clowns who are really giant spiders from
outer space and girls who in order to
maintain their psychic connection have
to have sex with a bunch of prepubescent
boys in it you know it's timing of it
yeah somebody was that's not now most of
what I think you were telling me that
you or Jim or somebody was telling me
that was it like the holey black mayors
are the black man that oh no people
people who try to claim is like Oh
Stephen King doesn't rely on cliches I'm
like the man single-handedly invented
the the trope that's called the magic
Negro I'm not I'm not making this up
that's Larry what's known you go to TV
tropes and like you know the really
Stephen King played a huge part in that
so and think you know think about the
Green Mile think about Shawshank
Redemption they you know God's sakes you
created Morgan Freeman's career and
that's tough for it
it's like wasn't like the black the wise
the wise man is a black man who has all
the answers and helps the white guy out
but but now that knowledge at now is
just trying Hispanic I saw devil I saw
Paranormal Activity - it's a spell
that's supernaturals - I had to Stephen
King huh I love that wake up take a
breath you smell that
it's deaf okay No - that guy's grid how
can you say that line to make it sound
credible you can that's a horribly
written wide it's dead oh this is a
start right like this is an original
series Star Trek set you're not even
looking at next-gen here there should be
Lizard Men walking around and a
shirtless no you know it is yeah it's
like it starts out as a scary clown
movie that just our Trek episode yeah or
a freakin Mystery Science Theater 3000
look at that now like that even when I
was a kid because I saw some ovy was a
kid it didn't really scare me boughs
with it up until that point and by this
is the last time I used the the original
nostalgia critic Zuko is it cuz it got
it got wet I got the fake blood on it I
got ulcer and it was falling apart so
I'm like okay he's giving the last time
I use it littles eyes but look at those
eyes and of course you gotta bring back
spiders Oh dr. Smith
I believe had way too much fun with that
dumb movie was like is this dr. Smith oh
wait wait yeah he does come up in the
lawston no spiders Doug doesn't come up
in lost in space cuz he actually does
have a liar's like you know a giant
legion of spied no a master race of
spiders then we change into giant League
you know I give Stephen King this and I
give the movie this as well now this may
be why I translated best in the movie
he's really good at writing friendships
like you get the camaraderie amongst
this crew this this group of kids and
the it comes through the film and I
think you've got like that is the
essence of the story
it's all the weird things around it that
kind of don't worry it's like that the
heart is really there and it's a shame
that like there's just you know a giant
alien spider and that's really good
actually that that's such a very good
point that the friendship always works
the conflict is usually where it gets an
i cuz i I really was enjoying the first
part of the film and I was like yeah no
I want you if you remove a lot of the
stranger supernatural elements of it
it's actually a really good story and
stuff like sperm and stuff like the
bullies oh I guess I think it's pre old
but yeah I yeah yeah actually I was
getting into that too I found hey what's
the point of this
oh no she's a zombie and now she's back
okay and she was we have five lines
she's gonna be okay folks five lines
well that's another that's a translation
problem when you have characters that
show up for all five lines like oh this
meant something if we didn't have to cut
like a hundred scenes a lot of rising
top of the hills snap her out I least as
Bertha malanga Weir's are we the new
people new people you will you will see
the review people cuz that was that
Babeu fun hey hey that had a psychotic
Balki ripping newspaper team in twenty
minutes
don't be so us you can do with that
that's gonna be fought and that's also
as a sanam Eliahu Larry the L'Engle
years and get you okay your stellar
performances coming up
Oh God somebody was like I think the
Razzie for the years you go to rob
walker I'm like thank you I'll gladly
accept it you know he tried really hard
that's right before I let you try get in
character he tried to believe he had
boobs that I was I did actually had
breast augmentation surgery yeah he went
to a lot of trouble you insignificant
bastards as fuck shit whores
well I was gonna go that far but I will
okay so this is where the line was is
like hey critic you think I look like
that asshole from it you know the one
who's always cracking jokes at Night
Court I pretty much just said just make
every weird Becca you don't usually have
a chance to make your weird fate you got
some good weird faces well my original
one was just a carbon copy of her and
then you're just like no make stranger
faces so I start off with the quivering
lips and I just did god no yeah it
starts off with her yeah here we go yeah
but that's it yeah that's her and then
it just go like I don't know what that
is I have no clue what any of this is
and that by the way that is ketchup
fanfic anti I did have fake fluff I
didn't work as well it is stick as well
so do do so yeah um no you have not
convinced us that it is any better I
give Stephen King props you know these
there's some great stories he's written
and there are great parts in it but yeah
dick curry is awesome though